I know this is Dr. Kevin Connors and we're going to go over your right tutorial how to use this machine that we're
decided to, every desire to help you in every way. So let's follow through this. This video is also
going to be on your computer itself. So if you need to review on how to use this, this is going to be
placed on your desktop of your right computer. So that will be a nice little benefit too. The pictures
that we use in this video, see these pictures here are in the back of your binder. So your new patient
binder has these pictures and it's as easy as pie. It's really easy. We tell people if you've never
used a computer, it's going to be a little challenging. If you know how to use a computer and
well it up to email somebody, it's you're going to be just fine. So it's fairly easy to learn.
So this picture here says there's some things that you need to know about the back of your
right machine. There's fuses that are extra fuses taped to the back of your right machine.
There may be an extra transistor. That's the thing with the little foe but it here. That is hot glue
to the back of your right machine and then there's two transistors that the yellow arrow goes to
that can heat up and burn out. That's why there's an extra one but quite honest they have maybe
replaced a dozen of these in a dozen years and it's because people used it not having it plugged
into a power search control or they had electrical storm or something like that. So that's where
you'll burn out a transistor. The other way that you'll burn out a transistor is if you run the
thing without the bolt plugged in. So don't do that. There is a child safety switch. If you're looking at
the machine to the right of the machine on the bottom but not in any of the newer machines. So if yours
is the newest model, it does not have the child safety switch. We're able to get that taken off, which
is very nice. So if you have a little bit older early 2017 model and before then they'll have a child
safety switch. Make sure that's toggled up. The front of your machine. The front of your machine has
a power button on the left. The output control right next to it, which is always need to be all the way
correct to the clockwise direction. The bulb toggle, very, very important. It says bath or bulb.
Always have it in the bulb position if you're using the bulb. Make sense? Well, what's the bath for?
Well, there is a second apparatus that you could purchase that plugs into the bottom right
hand corner of your machine. That big little plug-in thing that you're not using if you don't have
the bath apparatus. The bath apparatus is like an iron cleanse machine. It helps pull
step out of your like a bucket of water that you would put your hands or your feet in.
There is an accessory toggle that is that says color one. You could toggle that either way because
you're not using a color one ground. Then the bulb is plugged into the center of the machine where there's
a black plug and a red plug that your bulb has on the plugs, either a red or a black end to it.
You plug the red into the red and the black end to the black. Pretty easy. Then on the far right
upper, there's LED indicator lights. That has to do that the machine is running. It'll be a happy day
and paradise for you when you're a little indicator lights bird out because that's the most annoying
thing about the entire right machine of those indicator lights. In nine for a long time,
I actually put a piece of black tape over them to cover them up. They can burn out and work
and the machine is still running. That is something to look for. The right setup you're going to plug
in your computer. Your computer needs to be plugged into the same surge protector that you're
plugging in the right machine. You want to use a surge protector. This is a high voltage machine
that right is and you don't want it to be damaged by an electrical failure or surges in electricity
in your house for whatever reason. Plug the computer into that also. You should always have the
computer plugged in and you should always run it plugged in. If you're not running it off the
batteries, computers use produce like one-tenth EMFs. You always want to plug it in and use it off
of home power. You plug the USB from the right machine into the USB port. Make sure you plug it
into the USB port because when people call and say it's not working, is it plugged into the USB port?
No, sorry. Plug it into the USB port and then you plug the bulb in. The bulb again is red to red,
black to black. Then you put the bulb in your bed with you. I'm told you that in our house,
I have the right machine, the computer itself is sitting on the bedside stand next to my side of the
bed. Then we have the right machine itself is underneath our bed because to be the lights that
come out of the right front are the most annoying. When we moved our bedroom around, I took the black tape
off and cleaned it up but I put the right machine under the bed. Therefore, the wires that come out
of the front of the right machine will never get caught on somebody's foot and pulled out or something
like that. The wires come out of the right machine. They go behind my bed and they come up between
behind my headboard and the mattress and the bulb is always light in our bed. We make the covers
over the top of the bulb. You'll get used to it so that when you turn on the rife, it is going
to be ready to go. You get under your covers. The bulb is already shining and you're ready to go
and you're running your program. Your daily use is just that. You're going to time to go to bed.
You open up the computer because you've closed it the night before. You open up the computer. You
boot up the computer so that the rife, the computer turns on and you can see the little rife icon
on the desktop. Double-click on that rife icon because that's the rife program and you open up
the rife program. Then you go to your folder. If you have to hit open home, you can. If you hit
open, you'll go back to the folder that you were last in and then you go to your folder. This is
the first time you opened up the rife program. You'll want to hit open home and then you'll see a
whole bunch of folders. Remember, your rife machine you're going home with has
well over 1,000, maybe even 2,000 programs on it but the majority of the time you're going to be
using the programs that I created for you. I put it in a folder that has AA and your name so it'll
come up first alphabetically. It should be the top folder in the program. Double-click on the folder
and then you'll see your name under your name there. It'll come up Sunday by Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday Saturday. Whatever day it is today, you click on that day that will open up that day's
program and then you hit run and you run the program. It's literally that easy but don't forget the
next day, shut the computer. Once you hit run on the computer, it sends the program to the rife machine.
Literally, you could disconnect the computer and walk away with it if you want. The rife would then
continue to run that program until it times out. Now understand, I wrote the programs for you
that are longer than a typical person would sleep. Typically, I write 8 to 9 to 10 hour programs,
knowing that people are only going to be in bed 7, 6, 7, 8 hours because the end of what is going to
recycle back in. I just want, if you go to bed early and you're going to read a book or watch some
TV or something like that, I want you to get as much in as possible. You don't have to be sleeping
for this to work. Just run it. You're going to bed. You're going to be in the vicinity of the
rife machine. Turn it on. Get used to just turning it on. It takes an extra 30 seconds of the day.
Believe it or not, I've gotten people's rife back and I could tell if you use it or not because there's
a secret way for me to tell that. I've had people not do well and they look and see that they only
run their rife machine about one fourth of the time. It's like, okay, there's no excuses that.
So, make sure you tune it on every night. It's pretty easy. If you ever want to pause it,
you could hit the pause button and then come back and you have to hit pause again to unpause it,
but I tell you, why are you going to do that? Don't do it. Just leave it running. But I get up to
go to the bathroom because then get up to go to the bathroom. You'll get those frequencies again.
So, don't stop the machine. Don't open it up in the middle of the night and have to pause it.
Don't do that. Once you hit run at night before you go to bed, it's running. Don't change it.
Just let it run. If you have to get on, I have to get up and walk around for an hour. Well,
get up and walk around for an hour then come back and lay down again. So, do not stop it. Just run it.
Now, if you are running a program in the day or let's say you hit, well, it's Tuesday,
you actually hit Monday's program by accident. Oh, I just ran that last day.
Then hit stop and go back to open to get back to the file that you read or go to open home and then
back to AA your program and go to Tuesday and have run again. So, you could use stop. So, I tell people,
the top bar, the only thing you're really going to hit is open, run, stop and open home. Really,
that's what you're going to hit. That's all you're going to use. Now, you may, during the day,
run some other files. That's great. So, oh, I got really bad pain. My knee has been really hurting me.
Run the pain program. Oh, I just don't feel like I got a cold or flu coming up. Run a cold and flu
oncoming program. This is a wonderful tool. The biggest mistake I see with people with the right
machine is they don't use it. So, use it. Run some of the other programs. Do the same thing. Go to
open home. Look at the program you want to run. Click on it. There's a whole bunch of different
general use programs that you could use that can be extremely beneficial for you. So, use the
rife. There's no excuse. This should be your go-to for everybody in the house. Your child has a problem.
Use, does it ever, is there a rife program for that? Run the rife program. So, we get the
deepest testimonials from people who say, oh, I read it by planter, the planter awards program
and my planter awards fill up. Well, that's fantastic. Okay. It's not going to cure everybody's
planter awards, but planter awards are a virus. So, we run the program. So, make sure you use it.
Common questions. Can I use other electronics? Can I watch TV? Can I listen to the radio? Can I,
listen to, you know, by iPod while I, yes, you can. So, you can run other electronics while
running the rife. It may interfere with radio signals. We've had people say that I don't run the
radio in our bedroom, but we've had people say it makes the, you know, something go freaky with
the radio. That's a possibility. But yes, you can use other electronics. Nothing is going to
interfere with the rife frequency, right? The rife frequency might interfere with something else,
but the biggest complaint we get if it's a complaint, people say as they, they can get a static
electricity shocks. Yes, you can. You're running frequencies. So, if you're getting a lot of shocks,
there could be a couple possibilities. Number one, your house is very dry. That's a possibility if you
get a lot of static electric shocks with the rife machine. Number two, you are very dry, meeting your
dehydrated. Make sure you're hydrated. Number three, it can be just the frequencies that's running
at that time. So, many times, if it's running at a very high frequency, you're going to be more pro
to static electric shocks. And number four, we might need to use a ground in your man. So, just let
us know if it continues as it becomes really aggravated. And I will talk to you about possibly
using some ground. Next question, can we run night programs during the day? Absolutely. So, some
people's programs I already wrote you some day programs, run those during the day, or certainly run
any other programs you want during the day. On other people, I did not write you, you know, specific
day programs. You can run the night programs during the day and understand your programs are not
sequential. So, do I have to run blood day and then Tuesday and then Wednesday? What if I best stop
it? Actually, you ran Tuesday. Do I mess up the sequence? No, there's no sequence to them. So,
you can run a day program. I'm going to run blood day during the day, but I only read it for three hours.
Well, this is, stop it, hit stop. So, no problem with doing that. Next question, is it normal to feel
achy or cold or flu is coming down after using the right? Maybe, yes, and then what you got going on.
So, if we're doing a lot of kill programs, if you have Lyme disease or some other bacteria or
something like that, then yes, we don't want to hurt you. We need to move the ball away. So, if you're
listening to this and you're a Lyme patient, you cannot hurt. That's my rule number one. So, if you feel
achy after using the right, then we need to put the ball button to the bed or move it farther away
from you. For my cancer patients, if you feel achy after using the right, that's a good thing.
Suck it up and keep charging through because we're not herxing with the cancer patient. So, we are
killing cancer cells and we need to do that. If you have any other questions about this, make sure you
contact us or jump out our Zoom calls or whatever to get your questions answered. There's a whole
troubleshooting guide in the back of your binder. The biggest mistakes that we see that people make is
that it comes up a USB error. That's very common that the right frequencies will feed back to the
computer and it'll think that it doesn't have that USB connection. Sometimes you just need to unplug
the USB cable and plug it back in. Or the other mistake that we see people make is that they don't
power down their computer itself and reboot it enough. That's fine. I'm really bad at that.
So, if I get that USB error, if I don't unplug the USB cable and plug it back in and it doesn't work
right away, then I got to reboot the computer. You'll get also run error messages where it thinks it's
still running. Even though it's not running, it'll say you have to stop the it's running, it's still
running. It'll tell you that the program's still running. Just hit OK and hit stock and then hit
and then run it again. So, the whole idea is the whole problem is that we're running frequencies.
So, when you're running frequencies, it can feed back to the computer and the computer thinks it's
stopped or thinks it's still running and you have to just reboot that. The right program may state that
there's time left on the program or the countdown on the timer won't be accurate. You shouldn't
be looking at any help because your rule number one was to as soon as you hit run, you close the computer.
So, that shouldn't be an issue. Contact us or to write with any other technical issues.
Usually they're pretty easy to fix. If it's something with the the right machine itself,
true right is the person to help you with that. If you send it back to us, we can fix it. We have
to send it to them. So, we that's a rare happening though. The machine I am at home is at the time of
this recording is I think six years old and it still runs great. My son's machine is six years old,
still runs great. My daughter's machine is at least that old still runs great. So,
there's never really an issue. So, great. I hope this is helpful. Make sure you look at the guide
in your binder as well. Thanks.